hi I'm Stephen banks you've spoken about
the importance of four
those rights guaranteed to us in virtue
of where we are born but what is the
role of philanthropists and activists in
protecting the rights of those beyond
our borders well I think the role of any
of us philanthropists are not in
protecting rights beyond our borders is
nearly the same of course slanderous are
different they have resources they give
but you and I who may not have these
resources have an equal opportunity to
do what we can if we know that some
people are being mistreated far from our
shores and treated badly and there's
something anything at all that we can do
about it whether it means giving money
to some organization that's helping them
or doing something to take these people
from where they are and give them a
little sleep safe place I think it's our
obligation to do it so whether it
involves going in our pockets and
pulling out some money and saying here
this will help you out or whether you
and I say let's go there and do
something to help them I think we all
responsibility to do them we ought to do
it if we don't do it we're not worthy of
being the kinds of people we like to
think we are do you think that we're
doing more today than at a previous time
to be responsive to the needs of the of
the many I think we're doing more to be
responsible of the new of the needs of
the meanie medium sorry far away from us
then we were in my time perhaps in some
senses to the detriment of those people
who are right here in our own backyards
for some reason I think Americans have a
fascination with people who are far away
from them greater than the fascination
they ought to have with people who are
right around the corner but having said
that I think there's greater emphasis
now in helping people worldwide then
there was when I was at the age of these
students and I can't say that's a bad
thing